l'eau je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
moins vite sur messenger moore
fusionnelle voilà et ça nous fait
plaisir parce qu'il est très en forme et
la bonne nouvelle est vraiment je suis
très très heureux de ça c'est que
benjamin castaldi rejoint l'équipe de
touche pas à mon passé
[Musique]
dans la série la tour
cinquante ans
[Musique]
bon les séries the same as que tu es
content d'être avec mon frangin très
j'étais un peu long un peu la tente mais
c'est bien je compte même et c'est
toujours comme ça ça avec moi c'est
toujours ya beaucoup d'attentes
non mais c'est vrai vin mais c'est vrai
que on va pas se mentir ça a étonné
plein de gens qui nous rejoignent
on en 20 mois et tu sais quoi moi le
premier je sais mais comme disait ont
quand même
comme disait sheryfa luna il avait les
mots
[Rires]